hey Jessica right now pregnant Jessica
Simpson new details on baby number three
that is Jessica and husband Eric Johnson
leaving New York today he has earned
that in the 38 year old was there for a
series of meetings involving the Jessica
Simpson collections at the company
releases its fall campaign the video was
shot in late spring before Jessica was
pregnant a source tells us Jessica
suffered from terrible morning sickness
during her second pregnancy
oh good lord I don't think I could have
another baby right now but we've learned
so far she's feeling great although a
bit tired and in classic Jessica style
the singer is brutally honest about
pregnancy life she posted this pic in
bed and wrote this mama wants sleep and
as for cravings well yesterday she
posted a pic holding on giant Nutella
crepe and on Monday cinnamon rolls
Jessica revealed she's having a baby
girl on Tuesday and it turns out she was
keeping it secret during this surprise
performance last month
[Music]
Jessica saying with country legend
Willie Nelson in August five weeks
before revealing she was pregnant she
covered her baby bump and a loose
flowing mini dress
Jessica performed so rarely she pointed
out on Instagram that quote my husband
and kids got to see me perform for the
first time
[Music]